women are just so sick of softening our language for the benefit of men
I don't think I've ever actually said that I hate men on this app
um I've obviously spoken a lot about how men behave and how men treat us
and the benefits of decentring men from your life
and men choose to interpret that as misandry
hatred of men and
I always say and I love it when people say this is people tell you who they are
usually when someone accuses you of something
that is just not really making that much sense
or accuses someone of something that doesn't make that much sense
it's cause it's more about them
they're telling you who they are
they're seeing in others what's in themselves
so many men actually do have misogyny inside of them
and actually don't respect women and sometimes hate women
so when they hear women like me talk about men
they assume I hate men
and sometimes I wish that I did cause I think it would just be easier
but I think like
they don't understand the amount of patience and empathy we have for men like
that we can see beyond their hateful language and see that underneath that
they're actually struggling with the patriarchy in their own way
just the way we are and that doesn't justify the way that they treat us
you know an explanation
not a justification etcetera
but we know that when we speak about the behaviour of man
that the man who
other good ones won't be offended
they won't be defensive they won't think it's about them
they won't feel the need to lash out
and that's the point
we don't have to Panda to the ones who are the least worth pandering to
through our language
I don't know that there's many women who actually hate all men
I'm sure that every woman has men in their life who they love and respect
and a lot of the time we're really just talking about hating patriarchy
and hating how certain men treat us
and I think a lot of this nuance can be lost on this
on these apps if women had done to men what men have done to women
men would hate us a lot more than we hate them
and I think it's funny that they are struggling to hold the contradictions
that you might be strong and independent
you might be a feminist and you might still love men
wanna have babies I mean
I personally spent the afternoon mending things and sewing
and cleaning and cooking and like
you know like these things can all exist at once
but their goal is to put you in these binary categories
good woman or bad woman
they the very essence of the problem
is refusing to see women in their whole personhood
and understand that we contain multitudes
women contain multitudes and we just ask that we're seen
and respected as entire people and not put in these boxes
it's really important I think
not to be able to be pinned down by men as a woman or defined by men as a woman
and that's because that's the very thing that they wanna be able to do
and that's the very thing that will strip you of your full identity
and I think you know it
I do get a certain level of pleasure from like
seeing when they are confused about who I am
because they'll think that they've got me pegged as this certain type of woman
a man hating lesbian
or desperately lonely and unhappy or absolutely no fun at all
because it's much easier for them to just categorise a woman into ABC
cause we're so capable of so many things
like we're capable of being feminist and loving men and having babies
and hating patriarchy and hating some men
and hating cooking and loving cleaning
and hating our jobs and loving our jobs and wanting to be housewives
and then wanting to go out and get careers
and we're just capable of like all of it
and we're just asking that we have the freedom to exercise our agency
in this world without being judged disrespected
questioned made to feel unsafe
just in the same way that men are automatically given their agency
called entitlement in this world